اعلنت رياض تنفيذ عمليه اجلاء من السودان
شملت سعوديين واجانب من 12 دوله بينهم
دبلوماسيون ومسؤولون دوريون من جانبهما
اعلن الجيش والدعم السريع في السودان
استعدادهما لتسهيل حركه اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب من السودان بينما حذرت نقابه
الاطباء السودانيه من ان تكون هذه الخطوه
مؤشرا على فشل جهود وقف اطلاق النار وتوسع
الصراع
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله تكثيف
المجتمع الدولي جهوده لاجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب والبعثات الدبلوماسيه من السودان
في هذه المرحله من الصراع واي مؤشرات
تحملها الرؤى المقترحه لتنفيذ هذا الاشلاء
ما الانعكاسات المحتمل للتركيز الدولي على
اجلاء الاجانب والدبلوماسيين من السودان
على اي جهود محتمله للتوسط بين طرفي
الصراع في السودان وما فرص القوى السياسيه
السودانيه والمجتمع الدولي للتدخل من اجل
حمل طرفي النزاع على التفاوض لانهاء
الازمه في ضوء انصراف التركيز الى اجلاء
الاجانب من السودان
[موسيقى]
في اثناء هدنه كثرت خروقها حتى لم تبقى لم
يتبقى منها سوى اسمها تواترت التصريحات
بشان اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب والبعثات
الدبلوماسيه من السودان والذي قال الجيش
السوداني انه سيتم خلال الساعات القادمه
الجيش اضاف في بيان ان الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وفرنسا والصين ستجلي
دبلوماسيينها بطائرات نقل عسكريه تابعه
لقواتها المسلحه من الخرطوم وانه يتوقع
شروع في ذلك فورا
مطار الخرطوم الدولي اعلن تمديد اغلاق
المجال الجوي السوداني امام حركه الطيران
حتى الثلاثين من ابريل نيسان الجاري كما
هدد الجيش السوداني بانه سيتعامل بحسم مع
اي اختراق لاجواء البلاد
وكانت قوه الدعم السريع اعلنت استعدادها
لفتح جميع مطارات السودان امام حركه
الملاحه الجويه بشكل جزئي لتمكين الدول
التي تريد اجلاء رعاياها من نقلهم بسلام
واضافت قوه الدعم السريع عن الخطوه تاتي
تماشيا مع الهدنه الانسانيه التي اعلنتها
الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه والتي بدات صباح
الجمعه سعيا لتسهيل حركه المواطنين
والمقيمين بحسب قولها
وفي اول مراحل تنفيذ خطط اجلاء الرعايه
والدبلوماسيين الاجانب من السودان اعلنت
الخارجيه السعوديه اجلاء 91 مواطنا سعوديا
وسته وستين شخصا من رعايه دول اخرى بينهم
دبلوماسيون وبثت وسائل اعلام سعوديه صورا
لوصول مواطنين سعوديين وعدد من رعايه
الدول الاخرى في السودان الى جده على متن
احدى السفن الحربيه من الاسطول البحري
السعودي
ومع تصريحات دول مثل اليابان وبريطانيا
وفرنسا وكوريا الجنوبيه والسويد وسويسرا
وفرنسا والعراق والاردن والكويت وفلسطين
بشان اجلاء رعاياها من السودان قالت
السفاره الامريكيه في السودان انه ليس من
الامن حاليا اجلاء الرعايه الامريكيين وان
هذه العمليه محفوفه بالمخاطر واضافت سفاره
ان لديها معلومات غير كامله عن قوافل
كبيره تغادر الخرطوم وتواجهه الى
بورتسودان وان السفاره غير قادره على
تقديم المساعده لها ونصح البيان الرعايه
الامريكيين في السودان بالبقاء في منازلهم
وتجنب التوجه الى السفاره الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
في مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الخرطوم عبر الهاتف الرشيد المعتصم الباحث
في مركز الخرطوم للحوار من الخرطوم ايضا
حافظ كبير كاتب ومحلل سياسي ومن بوسطن
السفير الامريكي السابق في السودان مرحبا
بكم السفير كارني الى ماذا يؤشر تسارع
وتيره اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب من السودان
بتقديرك
بدا اود ان اتمنى فطرا سعيدا وعيدا مباركا
لجميع مشاهدي وطاقم عمل الجزيره ثانيا كل
سفاره في العالم مطلوب منها ان تصدر
تقريرا محدثا سنويا حول عمليه اجلاء
الرعايه والمواطنين الامريكيين وهذا
التقرير يشمل احتمال اجلاء
الرعايه لدول شريك الولايات المتحده
وهو بمثابه خطه بديله تكون متاحه لدى
السفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم عاده الجيش
الامريكي هو الذي يكون مسؤولا عن تنفيذ
عمليه الاجراء هذه ليس دائما فاحيانا قد
يسافر الناس من خلال طائرات ورحلات تجاريه
ولكن في الاوضاع الصعبه والحساسه الجيش
الامريكي
يناطوا بذلك
يبرر تعزيز القوات الامريكيه في جيبوتي في
حال كانت
بحاجه
السفير كورني اذا سمحت لي لا نريد ان نعرف
الاليه كيف تتم نريد ان نعرف الى ماذا
يؤشر هذا التسارع في وتيره اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب وان كانت السفاره الامريكيه تقول
ان هذه العمليه غير امنه حاليا
الفكره هي انه بدون شرح الاليه قد لا نفهم
لماذا يتم تسريع هذه الوتيره واضح ان هذه
الوتيره يتم تسريعها اولا لطمانه الناس
لاظهار ان الحكومه الامريكيه تهتم بهم
وتسعى الى حمايه امنهم ولكن في الحقيقه من
غير الامن نقل عدد كبير من الاشخاص الى
النقطه يمكن اجلائهم منها
وهذه النقطه ايضا غير امنه في الوضع
الحالي لا سيما في مدينه الخرطوم
السيد حافظ كبير كيف تفهمون هذا التوجه في
هذا التوقيت من الدول الاجنبيه
لاجلاء رعاياها من السودان
الغطاء الذي يمكن ان تشكله وجود البعثات
الدبلوماسيه في السودان عبر التواصل
المختلف التواصل معه دولي هذا الجهود من
اجل تحت تقديم المساعدات ايضا هذا الامر
سيكون صعب للغايه لان الاشعار السوداني
سيواجه لوحده بصيرا مجهولا سيظل يعني
الانسامات الحاده بين المؤسسه العسكريه
وكذلك هذا يشبه ما حدث في رواندا عندما
سحبت البعثه الدبلوماسيه مؤشر خطير هذا
الامر ويكشف يكشف الغطاء كبير كان يمكن ان
يساهم في حمايه المدنيين من العنف ويساهم
كذلك في جعل الاطراف تلتزم بصوره او باخرى
بالقانون الدولي الانساني وكذلك ان تراعي
حمايه حقوق الانسان خاصه واننا نتابع ان
الاطراف منذ بدايه الصراع لم تستجب لاي
مبادره داخليه والاستجابات التي جرت خلال
الفتره الماضيه هي
لجهود قامت بها باسات الدبلوماسيه وكذلك
سفارات خارجيه وابرزها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه السيد رشيد معتصم هل ترى فيه
مؤشرا خطيرا على السودان في الساعات
المقبله
هو ربما تطاول ابدا المعركه ودخولها في
الاسبوع الثاني ربما هذا ربما هذا احد
الاسباب التي دفعت الجلسات
والدول لاجلال رعاياها لكن انا يعني
القطر دائره دائره
يعني لا تتخطى يعني المعارك الان تدور في
في محليه الخرطوم يعني القطر الذي يمكن ان
يكون يعني في فيه يعني داخل المساحات التي
فيها اعمال حربيه لا لا
تتعدى 15 كلم من وسط الخرطوم يعني والان
الان انا اشهد انا اشهد يعني اليوم وامس
والبارحه ومن بدايه الاسبوع هناك بعض
المركبات العامه المواطنين عبر شركه نيل
من منطقه شرق النيل الضفه الشرقيه للنيل
من منطقه بحري الى محليه ودمدني وايضا
هناك المواقف العامه في الخرطوم تعمل
وتنقل المواطنين الى ولايه الجزيره حرك
ذائبه خلال اليوم
ايضا من النحل الشماليه والروايه الخرطوم
هناك سفر بالمرك خاصه الان يعني المواطنين
يخرجون من وسط المدينه من ضواحي المدينه
الشماليه
تقول الولايه ماذا تريد ان تقول سيد
المعتصم بالمناسبه هو المتحدث باسم القوات
المسلحه الجيش السوداني قال انه تم اخماد
ما سماه التمرد داخل السودان ولكن ياتي
هذا التوجه من الدول الاجنبيه لاجلاء
الرعايه هل هذا يعني بان الامور لم تستقر
للجيش السوداني بعد باقتضاب لو سمحت
المحدوده
يصور الدبلوماسيين وتصاور الدول القلق هذا
احد يعني القلق استمرار الحبل الاسبوع
الثاني يسبب قلق للدول والدبلوماسيين
نفسهم اسر ورعايه واطفال ونساء اكيد
يحصلون عن الامان يعني هذا امر طبيعي
لكن في كل الاحوال الان
هنا عمليه
الدبلوماسيين العرب عن طريق
الجنوب شرق
السودان
وجاء صوره عبر الميديا الاجتماعيه
والمواطنين استقبلوهم بحفاوه وكانوا في
امان حتى وصلوا بورسودان يعني عدد من من
البحثات الدبلوماسيه العربيه من ضمن
السعوديه ومن ضمنها قطر
فدائره
الخطر لا تتعدل 15 كيلو ثانيا هذه هذه
المعارك ليست معارك مفتوحه طيله اليوم
وهي لمعارف متحركه ومتقطعه خلال اليوم
يعني القادم سيد المعتصم هو الدول
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه تتخوف من القادم
خاصه اذا دخلت اطراف اقليميه في هذا
الصراع على كل حال السفير تموتي كارني
حماسه طرفي النزاع الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع على تامين خروج واجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب ما الرساله منه للمجتمع
الدولي بتقديرك وكدبلوماسي سابق
ربما هي نقطه مهمه يجب ان ننوه بها
ومفردها انه خلال عمليه الاجلاء
ليس بالضروره ان يتم اجلاء كافه افراد
الطاقم الدبلوماسيه ربما تكون الغالبيه
العظمى ودائما تسعى السفارات او تفضل ان
تبقي عددا من افراد طواقمها لكي تبقى
تراقب عن كثب الوضع الميداني حتى لو حصلت
عمليات اجلاء وحتى الان الظروف لم تسمح
بذلك انا ارى مع انني لست اكيدا لانني
متقاعد اذا ارى ان اتوقع ان نرى سفارات
تعمل ولكن بطاقم محدوده العدد حتى تتمكن
من البقاء على تواصل مع الطرفين الجنرال
البرهان والجنرال الحميتي
وتبقى حتى تلعب دور الوساطه من اجل
الاستمرار في الضغوطات للتوصل الى هدنه
ووقفا للاعتداءات تواصلنا الى وقف لاطلاق
النار ومفاوضات
خفض كبير مستغرب ان يعني يتم الاتفاق بين
طرفي الصراع على تامين ممرات امنه لاجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب خاصه من مطار الخرطوم لان
طائرات عسكريه ستحط لدول الرعايه وتنقلهم
من مطار الخرطوم بينما الاتحاد الافريقي
وايجاد يشتكيان من ان لا تستطيع بعثاتهم
الدبلوماسيه الوصول الى الخرطوم
للتفاوض على وقف اطلاق النار من مطار
الخرطوم كيف تفهم هذا التناقض
يعني هو بالطبع هناك اهتمام بالغ من قبل
الاطراف بالبعاسات الغربيه وخاصه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
ولكن هذا جاء في توقيت مختلف يعني عندما
يعني عزمت البعث الافريقيه القادمة
السودان كان هذا في بدايه الصراع كان
الصراع في اشد ايه لكن الان كما ذكر ضيفكم
هناك يعني شبه استقرار استقرت الامور على
حال من يسيطر على اماكن حافظ عليها حتى
الان ليس هناك حركه في
او او يعني تحرك للقوات ما بين الاماكن
المتنازعه عليها وبالتالي اعتقد ان
الاجواء الان افضل من الايام الاولى لكن
بشكل عام
يعني تستطيع البعثات الافريقيه وخاصه وهي
تجاور السودان عبر يعني دول مختلفه مثل
اثيوبيا وجنوب السودان تستطيع ان تاتي
وكذلك عبر دول اخرى منها
وكذلك عبر البحر الاحمر هناك يعني عدد من
المنافذ اذا اضطر الى ذلك لكن مساله
الاجلاء هي بالطبع مساله مختلفه غير يعني
بخلاف مساله القدوم الى السودان مساله
الاجلال هي اشبه بعمليه المحافظه على حياه
الناس من مكان خطر وبالتالي هذا يعني يعني
تستخدم فيه تدابير مختلفه ومن اجل اجلاء
الرعايه من الاماكن يعني تمثل خطرا على
حياه وهذا ايضا واحد من المهام وواجبات
تلك الدول ينبغي عليها ان تتصرف باي طريقه
لتدبير يعني عمليه
وكذلك تتخوف هي من مصير مجهول اذا ما لم
تتدخل بسرعه او لم تتدخل لادلالهم مثل ما
حدث مع
في ليبيا خاصه هذه الدول هشه علميا ويتوقع
منها يتوقع ان يحدث فيها تحت اي لحظه يعني
التفلتات واسعه حتى وان كانت البعثات في
مكان الامن حاليا وبالتالي هناك قلق من
قبل هذه الدول بشان الوصير باساتها
وبالتالي هي تفعل ذلك
كواحده من الواجباتها وكذلك تتعاون مع
الاطراف الذي نفهمه من خلال الاهتمام
والاطراف العسكريه داخل السودان بهذه
الفعل اهتمامها اهتمامها بهذه الدول
ومحاولتها لكسب موقف مواقفها ودعمها في
الذي في المواقف التي تتبناها وهي مواقف
بالطبع متناقضه ومتصارعه
السيد الرشيد المعتصم طبعا استمعت بان
الولايات المتحده تقول بان هذه العمليه
غير امنه حاليا المشكله ليست فقط بالطرف
الذي يسيطر على المطار وانما ممكن لاي
صاروخ او اي قذيفه ان تصيب ربما طائره
متوجهه من مكان ما لتحط بم طار الخرطوم هل
امكانيه تامين المطار لاتمام عمليات
الاجلاء ممكنه في ظل تصريحات من الطرفين
بانهم سيقومون بتامين هذه العمليه
التركيز في النزاع على هذه المناطق يعني
هي منطقه دائره القياده العامه والبطاق
قريب منها الاهداف يعني التي يتصارع
على الاطراف
ات مداخل ولايه الخرطوم المداخل في
اتجاهاتها السلام ممكن ان نقول يعني
يعني وراها هذه المداخل لا توجد لا يوجد
عمل عسكري
الغطر يعني هذا
القطري والمواطنين الان يتحركون نحوه
يوميا يعني كل يوم هناك حركه في اتجاه
الشمال حركه اتجاه الجنوب الشرقي وفي
اتجاه جنوب
بعض الدبلوماسيين هذه الطرق البريه يعني
وكانت امنه يعني مساحه لا تتجاهل لا
يتجاوز قدرها 15 كيلو متر والان في حركه
مستمره وفي توجد يعني
عامه وبعض المواصلات نسميها يعني ناس
يركبون القيمه يعني قد تزيد القيمه بعض
الشيء ولكن هناك مركبات منخف يتحركون في
الطريق شندي الان كثير من الاسر يعني
منطقه شندي الان يعني تحركت نحوها كثير من
الاسر بعد الاسر التي لها قارس في منطقه
عبره القضارف ولايه الجزيره الان يتحركون
الناس وحواء مدينه ود مدني كثيره انا
حاولي مجموعه من الناس لهم اقارب في مدني
يعني قاموا با
موسم اصلا البلد ما فيها نشاط اقتصادي وفي
موسم العيد ايضا هناك حركه لكن الخطوه وسط
المنطقه التي تركز
حول سيره لقوات الدعم السريع في مدينه
بحري وفي مدينه درمان ولكن لا تقوم بمشاط
عسكري واضح الا حينما تحصل مواجهات بينها
وبين القوات المسلحه باعتبار
الطرفين يا طرصدون بعضهم البعض ولكن
المعارك الان هي نفسها ليست معارك كثيفه
مواجهات مستمره لكن عارف متحركه من موقع
الى موقع
ما في حرب مفتوحه الان على كل حال السفير
كارنيه على ضوء انصراف التركيز الان
للدول الاقليميه وايضا للدول الغربيه على
اجلاء الرعايه من السودان ما فرص التوصل
لحل وقفه اطلاق النار دبلوماسيا
اعتقد انه من الواضح انه حاليا ليس هناك
الكثير من الفرص للتوصل الى حل دبلوماسي
فهذا يبقى
رهنه قرار الجنرال لين حميتي والبرهان علي
كل منهما ان يتحمل مسؤولياته ويقرر انهاء
هذه المغامره العسكريه الكارثيه ويبدا
باستئناف العمليه باتجاه حكم مدني في
السودان
سيكون هناك دبلوماسيون متواجدين والعواصم
سوف تتواصل مع دبلوماسيين حتى لو كانت قد
تم اجراء الغالبيه العظمى من طواقم
السفارات لان بقاء بعض الدبلوماسيين ضروري
من اجل الضغط على الاطراف المتنازعه في
الخرطوم وغيرها من المدن
السيد حافظ كبير كيف تفهمون هذا التخبط
بمواقف تاره الحديث عدم التفاوض مع قاده
الدعم السريع او من جهه اخرى حديث الدعم
السريع عن ضروره ازاحه البرهان وتقديمه
الى العداله واليوم برز الحديث عن لا بد
من جلوس على طاوله المفاوضات كيف تفهم هذا
التخبط في المواقف بين طرفي الصراع مع
الاسف فقدنا الاتصال مع السيد حافظ كبير
السيد رشيد المعتصم بعد ان قال السيد
برهان بانه لا تفاوض مع قياده الدعم
السريع اليوم يصرح ويقول بانه لابد من
الجلوس على طاوله مفاوضات مع كل الاطراف
كيف نفهم هذا هل هناك
ازدواجيه في القرارات داخل معسكر الجيش
السوداني والقوات المسلحه اذا صح التعبير
السودانيه وتفصيل الان ينظرون الى
غابه الدعم السريع باعتبار انهم اقرب
للماء في منهم الى السياسيين هم قاده
عسكريين تمردوا على القياده العسكريه
هاك ربط بين بين يعني شراء السلاح
والتجاره والاراضي
وخارجيه المشبوهه فهذه كلها مخيفه جدا
الوضع الذي يعني يمارسها او يعيش او
النشاط الذي يقوم به قاده الدعم السريعه
يخلق سقوط كبيره حولهم غير مطمئن وضعه غير
مطمئن السودانيين
ليس فصيل سياسي حتى يتم التفاوض معهم من
قبل الجيش
ففيها لكن الجيش قد يقبل اولياء
بالاستسلام ربما تكون هناك مثلا حفاظ على
الارواح حمايه لكن الدعم السريع كقوه كيف
لقوه سياسيه خارجيه
السيد المعتصم السيد البرهان قال بانه لا
تفاوض مع قياده الدعم السريع وتحديدا مع
حميدتي ولكن اليوم يتحدث عن ضروره الجلوس
الى طاوله مفاوضات كيف نفهم هذا التناقض
الامر باعتبار انه يعني التقليل من حده
القطار وتوفير الارواح والحفاظ على البنيه
التحتيه
لكن لا لا على على الدعم السريع كقوه
موجوده هذا امر مفرغ منه يعني هذه الحرب
لا بد ان تنتهي نهايه واضحه المعالم غير
ذلك الامر افتكر غير ممكن لانه يعني هذا
الدعم السريع وجودهم كفصيل مسلح يفاوض
يفوضوا كيف يفاوضوا وين يفاوضون وعلى اي
اساس يتم التفاوض هو الان يحولون ان
يخلفوا لنفسهم مشروعا سياسيا لكن نسوا
انهم هم عسكريين تمردوا واضافه
السريع السيد رشيد الدعم السريع لم ينشا
امس على كل حال في هذا السياق السفير
السفير كارني هل يمكن البناء على هذه
التصريحات الان عن انه لابد من جلوس على
طاوله مفاوضات بالمناسبه الناطق باسم العم
ليه السياسيه قال بان لا الجيش ولا الدعم
السريع كما يريدان هذه المعركه ولكن دفع
اليها من قبل مسماه بالنظام البائد
هل يمكن البناء على هذه التصريحات اليوم
بتقديرك السيد تيموثي كارني السفير
الامريكي السابق في السودان
هناك جانبان في هذه التصريحات
اولا قد تكون مجرد تصريحات تكتيكيه
لكي تظهر ما يبدو انه موقف منطقي من قبل
الجنرال البرهان النقطه الثانيه
هي انها موجوده وقد تؤسس قاعده لطرفين حتى
يجلس ويتحاوره
الان مع استمرار المعارك
لا يمكن ان نعتبر ان ايا من النقطتين فعلا
قابل للتنفيذ ويمكننا ان نفهم لماذا يتحدث
البرهان بهذه الطريقه السيد حافظ كبير
يعود الينا كيف تفهم انت من جهتك الحديث
الان عن امكانيه الجلوس لطاوله مفاوضات في
ظل هذه التطورات التي تحصل اجلاء الرعايه
التخوف من توسع الاشتباك في السودان ودخول
اطراف اقليميه ودوليه
هو هناك شكوك دوليه حول التزام هذه
الاطراف التي تتحدث بما تقول خاصه وانهم
لديهم تجاره معها عندما كان يعني المسؤوله
الامريكي الكبير مساعد وزير الخارجيه
لشؤون القرن الافريقي مع في اجتماعات مع
البرهان قبل انقلاب الخمس من اكتوبر عندما
غادر وقع الانقلاب كذلك اليوم هناك
التزامنه ولم تنفذ لذلك لا اعتقد ان اطراف
الدوليه وهي تستمع لهذه التصريحات يكون
لديها املا طبيعته
ستتحول الى ارض الواقع والا لما يعني سعد
بكل جهود هذه من اجل اخلاء وعاياها هناك
ايضا يعني
التصريحات في السودان احيانا تطلق من اجل
تحسين الصوره من اجل يعني القول بان هذا
الطرف يقال اللوم على الطرف الاخر هذا
واضح جدا اذا تابعنا تصريحات التي تاتي
تباعا هذا يصرح ثم يتبعه اخر بتصريح هذا
يلتزم بهدنه ويقول ان الطرف الاخر لا
يلتزم لان هناك يعني اشبه بعمليه السباق
نحو كسبي ثقه المجتمع الدولي لكن بشكل عام
يعني هناك فرصه اذا اذا
[موسيقى]
رغم هذه الارتباطات الخارجيه الواسعه
لطرفي النزاع لماذا فشل حتى الان في حث
الاطراف على وقف الاقتتال داخليا او على
الاقل الالتزام بهدى معلنه
اعتقد انه من الواضح انه في سنتين
الاخيرتين
ان المجتمع الدولي كان يضغط على كافه
الاطراف السودانيه من لجان
المقاومه او المسؤولين الحكوميين السابقين
ومن قام بالانقلاب الجنرالان البرهان
وحميتي من اجل سير في الاتجاه نفسه للعوده
الى الحكومه المدنيه ولكن الاسره الدوليه
ليس لديها ما يكفي من القدره من اجل
ارغامي
او
فرض ذلك هذا يجب ان ينبع من السودانيين
الشعب السوداني
وهذا ما فشل القائدان العسكريان في القيام
به وفشل في اداء واجبه مات تجاه دولتهما
واذا استمر الاسره الدوليه بالضغط
هذا لن يرغي مع احدا على التغيير شكرا لكم
السفير تيموثي كارني في بوسطن في الخرطوم
حافظ كبير كاتب والمحلل السياسي والرشيد
المعتصم الباحث في مركز الخرطوم للحوار
نهايه هذه الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر شكرا
لكم على المتابعه والتغطيه مستمره على راس
الساعه بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]